Can a nine-year-old with type 1 diabetes use a rife machine to heal?
Well, can a nine-year-old use a rife machine?
So it turns out what type of rife machine you're talking about.
So there's a lot of machines on the market that say that they're a rife machine
because there's no legalities about calling your apparatus a rife machine.
Rife is just the last name of royal raiment rife who came up and really put frequency healing on the map.
So there's a lot of machines out there that are rife machines.
We advocate to use the true rife brand rife machine
but also the GB 4000 rife machine is a good rife machine.
Can a nine-year-old use those machines? The answer is yes.
There really are no contraindications.
The GB 4000 can be a radio frequency background.
That's what it's usually to push. There can be some contraindications to that.
With the true rife brand there's no contraindications.
It is a true high frequency machine that's using light frequencies.
There's no contraindications for age.
You can use it pregnant women can use it little babies can use it.
People with implanted devices can use it.
There's no negatives to using it.
There's no as far as electrical devices nothing like that.
So is it going to be a good fit to use for type 1 diabetes?
I don't know.
Can you run?
Type 1 diabetes is an autoimmune attack destruction of the cells in the pancreas that make insulin.
Is the rife machine going to heal that?
I don't think so.
If I had a nine-year-old that had type 1 diabetes, would I try using the rife machine?
Sure.
Absolutely.
Can light frequencies be amazing and heal things that you never would have thought that that would heal?
Yes.
But we have to use wisdom too.
You know, is it the best tool for the job?
Well, there really isn't any tools that are going to heal an autoimmune disease.
You have to as far as like therapy goes.
Whether it's rife or whether it's laser or whether it's ultrasound or electrical stem or anything like that.
There isn't going to be a tool that's going to heal type 1 diabetes.
You have to deal with diet issues.
You have to look for triggers.
I have a whole course on autoimmune diseases, but definitely with type 1 diabetes, you have to control blood sugar levels.
You know, that could be deadly.
So if you're not under medical care to control those blood sugar levels as well.
So, but would it be something that you certainly could try?
Certainly.
Absolutely.
Would it be something that I would say that would be my first choice that I think this is going to heal it?
I don't think so.
But just try to be honest, you know, that it's just the rife and other therapies and other nutritional products.
And stuff.
They're just tools.
So they have to be properly applied just like, okay, I have a screw to screw in should I use a hammer?
Well, you could do the job with a hammer.
Is it the right tool to use?
No.
You know, you have to kind of board and have to use a hammer.
No, it's totally not the right tool for the job.
It's, you know, suppose you could break the board in pieces, but you certainly not do a very good job of it.
It's not the right tool for the job.
Same thing with the rife machine.
The rife machine can heal yourselves.
Could it be possible that it could heal yourselves?
Now, somebody might be listening to this and they say they might call in and say I used a rife machine to heal my type 1 diabetes with those child.
So I'm not saying that it can't happen, but I wouldn't it wouldn't be necessarily my first choice of that tool.